[Musique]
josée legault que l'on retrouve michel
david michels et roger bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir je vous fait entendre un petit
extrait de son point de presse on l'a
reçu tout à l'heure en entrevue mais
point de presse ce matin où madame hivon
qui a annoncé son départ de la vie
politique d'écouté ça n'a rien à voir
avec avec le score du parti québécois ma
décision était prise depuis longtemps
dit elle on écoute
les sondages ne mange jamais fait peur
d'ailleurs j'en ai fait mentir plusieurs
à la dernière élection ici même à
joliette et quant à marie victorin ma
décision était arrêté et connus de mon
chef plusieurs semaines avant l'issue du
scrutin six jeunes l'époque communiquer
publiquement avant c'était simplement
pour ne pas créer de possibles
interférences dans la campagne que nous
menions
marie-victorin campagne que le pq a
perdu on le sait deuxième à trente pour
ça madame ils vont quand même largement
remporté à chaque fois 44% de mémoire la
dernière fois 46 lot 3 4 élections dans
joliette elle avait des lots jeunes
adéquistes à l'époque josé de
commentaire général sur ce départ je lui
disais tout à l'heure bon elle est
respectée de tous ses adversaires
évidemment de ses collègues au pq ça va
sans dire
c'est une parlementaire
complètement hors norme à aller elle est
non seulement respectée mais je vous
dirais que lé même émis
dans le plein sens du terme et c'est
vraiment une politicienne atypiques etc
on
la louange beaucoup pour sa manière de
faire de la politique quand ce parti
dans ce qui est extrêmement rare
mais si elle est capable de faire ça et
qu elle le fait depuis de nombreuses
années dans des dossiers très difficiles
c'est parce qu'elle a elle eu
l'intelligence non seulement
intellectuelle mais elle est aussi une
grande intelligence émotionnelle et elle
est capable de transiger avec des
adversaires et elle est capable de
résoudre des conflits elle est capable
de les amener à travailler ensemble et
encore une fois les dossiers très dur là
comprennent seulement les soins de fin
de vie comprennent aussi le tribunal
spécialisé en violences
sexuelles et conjugales c'est pas des
dossiers facile ça elle est puissamment
contribué et beaucoup pendant qu'elle
était dans l'opposition c'est comme elle
vous a dit tout à l'heure j'ai quand
même pris fin en 14 ans de vie politique
elle a passé seulement 18 mois au
pouvoir
alors rivés sur chaque sens
c'est une belle leçon de politique oui
elle est terminée et les gay responsable
la dpj sont madame marois comme vous
êtes un
pendant le temps que ça dure et on
viendra sur l'impact sur le pq mais tour
de table ont continué sur madame hivon
ce qu'elle a amené michel david je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec les
commentaires de jose madame hivon était
dense au nord non mais c'est une perle
rare en politique je me souviens pas bon
on peut faire un parallèle avec
françoise david par exemple mais c'est
extrêmement rare de voir des gens qui
acceptent en fait de commandeur de
s'effacer derrière leur idéal et leurs
objectifs et madame hivon quand elle dit
écoutez moi je pense que je pouvais
accompli beaucoup de choses dans
l'opposition c'est vrai et elle l'a
démontré le problème c'est qu'il y en a
pas beaucoup de gens comme ça que ce
soit au gouvernement ou dans l'évolution
il y en a très peu dans un parlement de
sorte que nécessairement l'action
illimité et je comprends que madame
hivon avait
abstraction des sondages mais il faut
bien voir que son comportement est pas
celui des électeurs les gens élisent pas
quelqu'un sur la foi du bon travail qui
vont faire dans l'opposition et la
dernière fois ça avait été très serré
patrice dans joliette et cette fois ci
quand je regarde les tendances
nationales on peut facilement imaginer
que madame hivon russe ken défaite du
poker participe pour ça mais disons que
ça encourage - - à rester et on parlera
peut-être de l'impact sur le pq par la
suite mais honnêtement c'est une
catastrophe oui on va en parler tout de
suite après premier michel c départ de
madame hivon ça comme dinovo deux
collègues la vodka elle avait elle
incarnait quelques une espèce d'idéal
aussi d'accomplir des choses peu importe
le lieu où on se trouve au parlement
oui et le plus grand legs et laissent
les gens mourir c'est la loi sur les
soins de ville à l'aide médicale à
mourir peut-être que c'est le processus
par lequel on est arrivé là un comité
traces partisans qui a vraiment été
transpartisane n'a pas beaucoup
d'exemples de ce soir à l'assemblée
nationale ou à chambre des communes ces
dernières années et ce processus là et
du avec un équipement car c'est un
gaudreault puis la mère d sion il ya
quelques semaines j'avais dit
l'assemblée nationale vont être moins
bonne place saint sylvain gaudreault
cheveux je joue est obligé de dire la
même chose pour véronique hivon
l'assemblée nationale perd quelque chose
quand on perd quelqu'un quand véronique
hivon puis le lait qu'elle rêve c'est
quand même un processus pour arriver
à des résultats d'avoir d'aussi que la
plupart des gens disent mal aussi c'est
trop chaud ça marchera peut pas toucher
à ce qui était le cas le mourir bon
allongée sur le terrain politique plus
partisan effectivement pour le parti
québécois bon michel la dernière fois
j'avais donné le résultat de l'autre
avant je crois mais la dernière fois
vous avez raison je pensais plus serré
donc elles n'étaient pas assurés de
gagner avec le rouleau compresseur
on va voir le sondage tout à l'heure de
la cac chez les francophones
est-ce que ça a joué d'une part et
d'autre part l'impact sur le pq je
commence avec vous monsieur david
chassot jpy jose après
madame ils vont nous dit que ça a pas
joué mais bon
on va l'accord sur parole disons mais
des résultats comme ça c'est encouragent
personnes à poursuivre une campagne une
carrière pas il sait que disons c'est
comme ça et ça pose le problème de la
relève aussi les gens se disent bombe et
même une véronique hivon
c'était pas évident alors imaginez la
course aux candidats qui est déjà pas
simple en général mais qui devient
terriblement compliqué quand on demande
à quelqu'un de laisser un travail un
poste intéressant pour une aventure
extrêmement aléatoire écoutez quand on
regarde les sondages d'aujourd'hui puis
qu'on a c'est d'extrapoler ça peut
vouloir dire
zeev au siège ou en admettant que pascal
bérubé par exemple dames attendent qui
lui aussi était
commandé cinq clients un fief il ya un
fief personnel
dans matin il peut être le seul de le
dernier des mohicans la prochaine fois
alors non non c'est très très lourd de
pect non seulement par la personne mais
pour le symbole enfin l'avenir que le pq
peut encore espérer il reste 7 michel
cei sur l'impact sur le pécule
ya deux impacts d'abord un impact très
géographique là c'est le dernier député
qui était dans quelque chose qui pouvait
ressembler comme le très grand montréal
elle était de tous les autres en 200 de
l'est du québec c'est pas un détail et
d'autre part
c'est quelqu'un qui est jeanne
reconnaissait et instantanément comme
une phase du parti québécois et quand on
perd des gens comme ça on perd une
partie de l'histoire du parti mais aussi
de son avenir 2 des voix si quelqu'un
qui pour être ministre de quelque chose
de très sérieux puis bon ça il ya pas ça
maintenant il est le dernier qui a déjà
été membre d'un cabinet c'est parce
qu'elle publie comme je le disais il
pourrait après de se présenter
végétariens ou max et ses milices
d'harmattan qu'il ya un appareil mais
pour les antilles rien d'acquis là
dedans et
quelqu'un qui parle comme ça même si
c'est pas pour ces raisons là
ça reste qu'elle ne sera pas deux
équipes ont en revanche départ puis ce
magistrat lui et ça envoie un message
que l'équipe a perdu quelque chose de la
maison ça nous plaît bien sûr josé si
évidente
oui c'est une lourde perte pour la
famille nationale mais aussi pour le
parti québécois mais très franchement là
les problèmes au pq sont tellement
profond ils sont tellement lourd à
porter comme on vient d'expliquer la ce
et c'est possible on n'a pas de boule de
cristal mais c'est possible que le parti
soit presque rayés de la carte à la
prochaine élection c'est quand même une
possibilité là pour la première fois de
son histoire
donc même si madame hivon et de respect
est ce que ça aurait vraiment changer
quelque chose à cette espèce est dessine
depuis plusieurs années et comme vous
l'aviez dit face au rouleau compresseur
de la caq écouter dans ma vie viktoria
szabo est une partielle on a vu le parti
québécois était capable a été incapable
de la conserver même avec un candidat
vedette donc écouté comme d'aider à
régler
quand c'est écrit sur les murs non mais
c'est difficile de voir autre chose je
vais je vais le montrer le sondage
justement intentions de vote au québec
qu'un sondage dans votre journal josé
journal montréal de québec ce matin
léger et ils caracolent c'est
l'expression que j'ai utilisée à 44 % +3
17% pour madame anglade le plq 15 pour
le québec solidaire 13 pour les
conservateurs et 9 on y arrive pour le
parti québécois ça ce que ça veut dire
c'est que même matane comme disait
michel françaix que vous michel c mais
même matin ce n'est plus un château-fort
nécessairement pour le pq pour bérubé
même si comme vous dites il pourrait se
présenter mais il n'y a plus rien sur
l'acac avec c'est celle là je pense
qu'on va voir chez les francophones sont
encore plus forts évidemment on arrive à
50% chez les francophones on le voit
il peut tout ramasser le goal
oui le problème de notre système
électoral puis bonbons pour faire des
courses à proportionnelle mais c'est que
quand il ya plusieurs parties qui ont
qui peuvent avoir autour de 10% des voix
fille en a un qui est plus rock que les
autres c'est lui qui rafle tout
alors je suis le groupe facilement avec
44 % du vote se retrouver avec plus de
90% des sièges à l'assemblée nationale
après sa bonne chance à lui passé très
difficile comme situations à gérer mais
sait on peut pas commander le nombre de
sièges qu'on veut avoir mais il va y
avoir à présent un problème tellement
démocratique parce que ils risquent
littéralement de tout balayer et un
moment donné on est quand c'est arrivé
deux fois monsieur bourassa d'après
d'après il était battu c'est pas pour
rien c'est parce que à un moment donné
on écoute - des gens aussi on est on est
moins
par des compromis alors
déjà qu'ils seront pas tellement beau
dans le
contre-projet mais
qu'est ce que ça nous dit donc josé
michel david sur cette relation qui
s'est installé entre le vote francophone
et la cac
dans le cas de monsieur legault y aurait
eu si totalement son pari de prendre
toute la place l'ats michel
lagarde le grand motif de satisfaction
je pense de monsieur legault la dame ça
doit être la même chose le soir de la
partielle c'est que là il voit que
l'hypothèque de la coved là ne le
une nuit absolument pas en huitièmes pas
aux rigueurs d'aucune façon de la
gestion de la commune de la pandémie y
compris d'ailleurs dans les ces achats
soldés alors pour le reste monsieur
legault a établi depuis son arrivée un
lien
avec la majorité francophone qui est qui
qui presque reagan et que diraient les
gens se reconnaissent dans le gault
pendant depuis le début nous parle de
fierté de tous alors que quand on arrive
sur le terrain le les gains que le
québec a fait part sur le sur
l'échiquier canadien
sont minimes
l'autonomie que la caq pro nos efforts
elle s'est plutôt traduite par des
reculs depuis que le gotha river on le
voit le gouvernement fédéral qui a
envahi à chaque à chaque année davantage
de alors c'est comment dire monsieur
legault
est un espèce incarne la résistance la
défensive mais ne fait pas progresser
les gens mais de toute évidence c'est
pas ça qui qu'il réclame et il faut bien
le dire on à monsieur legault il est
tout seul sans glace là il ya personne
parmi les chefs des différents partis
dans lesquelles les gens voient un
premier ministre et dans l'urne la
question que les gens vont se poser
c'est qu'ils veulent avoir comme pour
diriger québec pendant les quatre
prochaines années et honnêtement
personne très peu y voit un des quatre
autres occupé ce poste aurait il faudra
jauger on se dit il faut être prudent
c'est dans six mois mais quand même là
il ya des il ya des tendances de fond
qui se dégage il ya le moment le gaulois
et les québécois vivent leurs moments
legault
une bible l'époque le groupe beaucoup
plus qu'un moment le goût on peut parler
de l'air le goût et c'est une ère qui de
toute évidence va durer beaucoup plus
que
j'ai beaucoup aimé la manière dont mme
chan à vis de la dcri je suis le mot
symbiotique
une relation symbiotique s'est installée
entre françois legault une majorité de
francophones écoutez malgré l'apport des
mous pour quand même le dire malgré les
5000 morts de la première vague je dis
pas que c'est un cerveau mais j'ai dû
quand même et on a quand même très très
dur
pour publier kaka qu'en 2018 a été élu
avec 37% des voix et depuis ne cesse
d'augmenter
abbas est appuyé membres et mêmes qu'à
la fin du printemps 2020 donc à la fin
de la première vague
la cac avait même monté à 51 % des puits
à travers le québec s'était monumental
donc il ya quelque chose de très
puissant et je pense que monsieur le
goût de trouver la recette c'est à dire
qu'il est devenu un miroir alors il
renvoie la majorité des francophones
l'image de main il rend bois sont ceux
où ils sont rendus politiquement donc
plus vraiment souverainiste le
fédéralisme renouvelé ou ci sera et bleu
est mort donc on fait du nationalisme
faut nécessairement de l'autonomisme la
com com les comédiens michel mas du
nationalisme et on le bus tout de suite
avec la loi 21 sur la laïcité qu'est ce
qu'il a fait il ya pris il ya plus
milieu il n'y est pas allée avec la
charte des valeurs du pq qui était
beaucoup plus radicale n'est pas non
plus allé avec les dénis de fait des
couilles à retrouver un petit chemin un
milieu et puis c'est bien trois ans sur
la ville avec la modernisation de la loi
sans y trouver cheminots ligne-là pour
pas trop déplaire qui veut pas étendre
la loi 101 au cégep parce qu'il sait que
ça mettre en colère book francophone
donc c'est un miroir finalement c'est
intéressant on va ajouté il est redonné
vécu ça devait faire un homme en fait
c'est le gouvernement qui ressemble
beaucoup à un gouvernement péquiste jean
bernard
qui est intéressant dans l'économie soit
en salle de faire comme sale affaire qui
divise vite les gens veulent plus tessa
s'il a fait la synthèse
le livre le français chez au cnc c'est
lamentable ça n'existe pas on va écouter
monsieur legault justement quand vous
dites sur la défense du français ils en
parlent beaucoup
et monsieur le trudeau je pense vient de
commenter je pense qu'on associe on va
écouter tout ce qu'on fait
c'est inacceptable que le cn n'est pas
de représentants québécois francophones
sur son conseil d'administration on a
parlé à direction du cn et la semaine
prochaine leur assemblée annuelle des
actionnaires qui vont annoncer qu'ils
vont nommer quelqu'un de québécois et
francophones
j'ai été honnête j'ai été époustouflé
d'entendre cette situation là qu'une
compagnie comme la cn compagnie
nationale assujettie aux règles
fédérales assujettis à la loi sur les
langues officielles n'ai pas vu ce qui
s'est passé à air canada est pas appris
la leçon qui me semblait tout à fait et
me évidente je comprends à quel point
les gens sont frustrés moi aussi je le
suis alors j'ai demandé au ministre
approprié de s'assurer que la cn travail
rapidement pour rectifier la situation
ça vient d'entrer ça monsieur trudeau
qui se dit
abasourdie d'une certaine façon tour de
table à tulle cn presque pire élève cair
can en tronçons à peu près dans le même
coin josé la différence éclats le québec
a un gros financiers par la caisse comme
monsieur legault à dispo vrai que ça va
continuer comme ça
oui mais sauf que ça a été fait et
le départ de jean charest qui est allé
se présenter à sa batterie est nommé sur
le conseil d'administration et si
presque à se demander
au delà du fait que monsieur charest
tête un ex-premier du québec si sa
nomination était pas une nomination de
façade finalement parce que une fois
qu'il est parti qu'est ce que fait le cn
il se retourne puis trouve pas de
québécois francophones et anglophones
bilingues ou de simplement quelqu'un qui
sait parler français correctement bon
alors c'est pas si pas les bons
administrateurs qui montrent pourtant et
monsieur charest sauf erreur je n'en
parlais en entrevue ce matin avec un
patrick masbourian pis je n'ai pas
entendu condamner sa non plus un petit
peu de blagues à la ferme se marrent
fraude parce que je suis parti etc mais
écoutez c'est quand même raflé la
nonchalance d'un irrespect et keith qui
s'escrime dans ce qui s'est passé à air
canada et en tout respect pour monsieur
trudeau et on veut pas revenir sur cette
nomination là mais bon il reste que il
aussi nommé un gouverneur général qui ne
sait pas parler français
il ya quelque chose qui se passe là et
c'est à se demander comment ça va finir
par se régler en jour michel d'avesnes
chat sur oger conclusion là dessus
ccn je le rappelle c'est chasser al à
montréal vous allez me dire ce programme
mais c'est comme ça mais chez moi je
suis pas surpris du tout de ce qui se
passe au cn il y a un an à peu près il y
avait eu une cause d'un fonctionnaire
fédéral qui t'es pas au cn mais qui
était dans un organisme fédéral qui se
battait depuis une dizaine d'années pour
avoir droit de travailler en français et
il le sait n était intervenue dans la
cause pour expliquer que par exemple
chez eux là quelqu'un qui veut parler
français alors que tout le monde parle
en anglais ça fonctionne la poste n'est
pas possible d'établir le français comme
langue de travail même dans les
districts
identifient comme bilingue par le
fédéral alors c'est dérangeant c'est
fatigant il n'aime pas ça à voir des
français et je pense que le cn reflète
en grande partie la culture du canada
tout entier il ya une petite minorité
qui trouvent que de bilinguisme et
quelque chose ils ont ici mais pour la
plupart des gens c'est simplement un
irritant con qu'on essaie de gommer le
plus souvent qu'on peut michel
sauget conclusion 1 en plus de ça c'est
connu dans le monde des affaires les
goblins frère ce tableau presque plus
rétrogrades depuis dinosauriens qu'on
peut trouver asseyez de négocier que le
cp ou le cn doit avoir un petit bout de
terrain qu'ils ont déjà acheté dont ils
ont pu besoin vivons vous dont vous
traîner sa voix dans 10 ans alors ils le
sont aussi sur question linguistique le
bas avec l'eau merci beaucoup à vous
trois très intéressant qui ont eu un
oeil au beurre noir c'est un art plus en
voulant acheter le
le réseau nord américain bref ça se noie
histoire adieu à bientôt au revoir à toi
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit